so when president trump has been saying
that he is up against not just joe biden
but also up against social media and big
tech and the media he is not lying
the latest indicator of a media that
does not wish to cover stories it does
not wish to cover
is what's happening in philadelphia so
you've had massive rioting over the past
three nights over the shooting of
walter wallace okay walter wallace is
being portrayed by democrats as a very
nice guy
a very very nice guy here's bernie
sanders tweet on walter wallace
so bernie tweeted out walter wallace
would be alive today and our thoughts
are with his loved ones
the police responsible for murdering him
in front of his mother instead of
getting him the medical attention he
needed
should be arrested investigated and
prosecuted by the justice department
okay so bernie sanders says this guy is
murdered murdered like in cold blood
like they should be prosecuted
federally by the justice department says
bernie mcsanders
okay there's only one problem he was
holding a knife they told him put down
the knife many times he was then ten
feet of them
he kept approaching them they shot him
also
it turns out that walter wallace was not
the world's nicest man
i know that we have this um this duty
every time
a black man is killed by the police to
portray that black man as
the font of all good innocence and
wonder
we got this with jacob blake who turns
out was an alleged rapist
we got this with george floyd and it
turns out that george floyd literally
held the gun to the stomach of a
pregnant woman a few years prior so
that does not mean that what happened to
george floyd should have happened to
george floyd it does mean that it does
not require you to treat
people who are shot by the police or
killed by the police or die in police
custody
as wonderful wonderful people in order
to make your point about police
brutality with regard to george floyd
it certainly means in the case of jacob
blake that you know the democratic
candidates
calling up jacob blake personally to
offer their condolences to him on being
shot after he resisted arrest went for a
knife in his car
and had been called to the scene by a
woman who alleged rape against him
previously
that's it it makes for a weird narrative
well it turns out that
walter wallace was not world's nicest
human being according to 6abc.com right
local news covering this wallace was an
aspiring rapper with social media
accounts filled with videos that sounds
nice doesn't it
well oh well oh yeah guns are a central
theme as he rhymes about shooting people
including police
but his videos also include songs about
social causes and police and justice
see this has always been weird to me if
you cut a song
about how you're shooting the police and
then you're like but the police are mean
to me
i feel like the police might have a
reason to be mean with you if you're
talking literally about
how you want to shoot them and murder
them in any case it's not just about his
rap obviously people rap about a variety
of topics many of them wrap fictionally
walter wallace has a criminal record
court records show wallace was currently
awaiting trial for allegedly threatening
to shoot a woman and her house up
in 2017 he pled guilty to robbery
assault and possessing an instrument of
crime
after kicking down the door of another
woman and putting a gun to
her head he was sentenced to 11 to 23
months behind bars
in 2013 he pled guilty to assault and
resisting arrest after punching a police
officer in the face
so um yeah that's uh that's not great
that's not great bob
okay but all of this resulted in massive
riots in
philadelphia and um our media covered it
in exactly the way you've become
accustomed to our media covering riots
they decided to downplay it pretend that
it was the
looting was the was the language of the
oppressed when you're that oppressed
like in philadelphia or democrats have
been in charge for almost literally ever
well that means that you're oppressed
enough that you got to steal a tv so new
york reporter tweeted out new york times
reporter reporter tweeted out
why are we even covering this eric
lipton watching my twitter feed since
last night
very notable the intensity of tweets
from conservative voices looking to
amplify
draw attention to looting in
philadelphia yes it happened new york
times covered it as well
just remarkable how conservatives want
to elevate it i
i feel like it's more remarkable how the
media wants to downplay it
massive riots in which a thousand people
loot a walmart
after the justified shooting of a person
trying to attack police with a knife
it seems to me like that should be more
newsworthy than the
top story that the new york times and
everybody else was covering yesterday
which was trump held a rally in omaha
and the transportation was not good and
some old people were stuck in the cold
that was literally the top story on
twitter all day yesterday all day
right so there's massive rioting which
is an act of mass criminality in
philadelphia
and the local authorities look the other
way or cater to it
that's not a story it's a story that the
transportation plans in omaha were not
very good
huge huge break yes don't worry there is
no media bias virginia
there's no media bias whatsoever then
there's a the the idiots like wolf
blitzer my favorite is when joe biden
talking points just sort of
wander their way in via the media so
here's wolf blitzer saying i don't
understand why the philadelphia officers
didn't just shoot to wound
the reason you don't shoot to wound
idiot is because you're not that good
with a gun
no one is that good with a gun nobody is
jack bauer other reasons you shoot for
center of mass because if you shoot to
wound there's a better shot that you
miss
and hit an innocent bystander there are
many reasons to shoot
other reasons to shoot not to wound
because sometimes you wound the person
and they keep coming after you let's say
they shot this guy in the leg and he is
now within three feet of them with a
knife because he's approaching them
is that going to work out well i think
now but here's wolf blitzer being a
complete dunder head because this is
what we do in the media now
walter wallace had a knife as we saw one
witness said though he had mental health
issues the district attorney
said a report this uh was a medical with
it was a medical call was consistent
with what they know so far so could
these officers have escalated the
situation
uh if they obviously could have used
tasers if they had tasers but they
didn't have tasers
but why shoot to kill as opposed to
shoot to
injure and just prevent anything from
going further
okay because you're an idiot wolf
blitzer and the answer is because that's
the stupidest thing i've ever heard
but again more important to cover the
evils of cops who didn't actually do
anything wrong than to cover what's
actually happening in the city
so the pennsylvania governor tom wolf he
called the rioting peaceful protests he
literally said this okay so here is
governor wolf
i'm my staff and have been in constant
communication since last night
with the folks in philadelphia and the
hope is that that
doesn't escalate into anything more than
than the peaceful protests that
that i think this kind of situation
brings out
oh well you know we all have hopes don't
we we all have hopes but those hopes
were not justified also as it turns out
um it turns out the police were told to
let the looters loot according to jazz
shaw writing over at hot air the mayor
of philadelphia imposed a curfew last
night in an attempt to quell the ongoing
rioting and looting
shockingly many of the people who were
already in the process of breaking any
numbers of law did not follow the orders
and set out to continue the mayhem so
why would the looters continue emptying
the shelves of all the city stores after
they'd been put on notice by the
municipal government
perhaps it's because they'd heard that
the cops had been ordered not to arrest
any looters
yes you heard that correctly the cops
were told to simply disperse the looters
and not take them into custody this
comes from one of the local fox news
reporters who heard it directly from
multiple police sources
steve keeley reporting obtained by fox
29 news
directive from philly police executive
team extremely frustrated officers both
patrolling commanders told me overnight
they were ordered not to arrest looters
just
disperse them okay that is incredible
that is incredible okay as you may
recall daniel outlaw who is the current
philadelphia police chief took the
office of police commissioner on a
promise to put an
end to the incarceration nation that we
all supposedly live in she's been one of
the biggest proponents of the empty the
jails movement in the country
in case you weren't aware of her history
prior to coming to philadelphia she was
prior the chief of police in
portland oregon so yes it turns out
that these major cities being left to
the predations of local officials who do
not care about rioting and looting or
see the writing and looting as justified
response to the systemic evils and
racism of america
that is a big story and it's a big story
in a swing state so naturally the media
don't want to cover it
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content